all right it's a collection 75 years in
the making the lvcva has released some
of these images documenting the
important moments in las vegas history
from casino openings all the way to
presidential visits and as you're going
to show us for the first time ever these
moments captured on camera are being
released to the public online
from the opening gala at caesars palace
in 1966 to this 1953 poolside image at
the sahara used to promote las vegas and
the great weather with the slogan fun in
the sun they are part of the 75th
anniversary online collection from the
lvcba's news bureau promoting tourism we
wanted to go with the images that people
recognize the most published kelly luck
is the archivist behind this nine-month
project she says some of the negatives
are 75 years old requiring extra care we
scan the negatives we digitize them we
re-house them into archival materials
and then we freeze them each image like
this one with president john f kennedy
or liberace on top of a birthday cake in
front of the sahara was used to help
promote las vegas and the unique life in
the desert
luck says even the atomic mushroom cloud
was uniquely portrayed in several photos
you see
vegas vic the pioneer club sign and in
the middle is an atomic mushroom cloud
and it ended up being one of the most
published photos of las vegas in the
world the las vegas convention and
visitors authority says the collection
of more than 7 million images and 11
thousand film and videos began back in
1947 with the focus to promote las vegas
today that concept remains intact
entertainment the dining the shopping
you see that in the images of the 40s
50s 60s and you still see that today so
while it's different it was smaller it
was more formal that overall emotional
reason that excitement that you want to
come to vegas is still there
those pictures are amazing all right we
have a link on our website 8newsnow.com
to see the full 75 images now lbcv8 says
there will be an additional group of
pictures released very soon focusing on
celebrities right here in las vegas each
picture has a brief summary of its
history looking forward to checking that
out awesome stuff all right